Germany's air ambulance service has
never been busier these helicopters are
being used to move critically ill
coronavirus patients from one hospital
to another the wards are beginning to
fill Europe's biggest nation took early
action to try to stem the advance of the
virus it was well prepared but not
immuned now the number of deaths is
rising fast but for the pilots and crew
this isn't just about Germany
the helicopters stationed here have
flown into France and Switzerland to
collect patient's others have gone to
Italy and beyond but finding that
precious place in the hospitals is
getting harder some problem national you
see it's a national problem for us here
as well as in France but there are
hotspots spread across the country some
hospitals have beds available in ICU and
others are already full within these
helicopters is this transparent pod a
norwegian invention called an epi
shuttle it isolates the patient while
they're being transported
we saw it tested using a healthy
volunteer air is pumped into the pod and
then cleaned as it leaves they've a
complete filter system here from the
upper side gets you to filters and we
have the same filter types as well
inside of baby shuttle so you can be
sure that no virus comes out through our
ventilation all this means the crew
don't need to wear cumbersome protective
equipment so they can react fast and
they do Germany has a formidable medical
infrastructure here's an example it's
got Europe's biggest fleet of 24/7
ambulances and the team here are going
off to their first call out of the day
to Rockville about 50 miles from here
Germany has tested a lot of people and
it's testing more and more it has a
massive well-equipped hospitals it still
has empty beds a contrast to neighboring
countries many of them struggling under
the weight of patients needing intensive
care
across the border in france's eastern
region hospitals are full capacity we
were taken inside one of france's most
under-pressure wards in Colmar this is
the life support ward at the town's
hospital home to its most critically ill
patients the demand for beds here is
enormous
every time one becomes free there are at
least 10 requests to use it 170 patients
have already been transferred from here
to other hospitals by road rail plane
and helicopter but one said that
constantly adapting how we work without
really knowing if it's right or wrong
but we do our best it's just not easy as
a doctor flying blind in this situation
we are just not used to it this sort of
cross-border cooperation doesn't
normally happen but now under grim and
intense pressure it is working lives are
being saved at imperson Sky News Rhine
monster Germany